sometimes it's not fake news it's just
wrong news sloppy fact-checking not done
sloppy reporting this morning CNN
breathlessly delivered that they
advertised this major scoop breaking
news in the Russia investigation and to
CNN exclusive reports this morning newly
surfaced emails show an effort to give
hacked wiki leak documents to the Trump
campaign Trump jr. others in the Trump
Organization received an email in
September 2016 offering a decryption key
in website address for hacked WikiLeaks
documents now this is according to
september 4th 2016 email you now know
looking at timings at mana reported that
Don Jr the president's son tweeted about
WikiLeaks for the first time the same
day that this email that he doesn't
recall came through politically just
difficult for the team or legally some
implications here one little problem
they got the date wrong this shows the
email was sent to John jr. last year on
September 14th and not the fourth that
was after WikiLeaks had already made
those documents public leaving CNN once
again with a fried egg on its face this
was just the latest in a long line of
media screw-ups look at these examples
from just the past seven days in
addition to the CNN mistake ABC News
incorrectly claimed that candidate
Donald Trump directed Mike Flynn to
contact Russians during the 2016
campaign it actually happened when he
was already president-elect big deal and
the New York Times had to heavily amend
a report that former Trump aide katie
mcfarland lied to Congress about Flynn's
communications with the Russians and
multiple outlets walk back stories that
Deutsche Bank received a subpoena from
Bob Muller targeting Trump's bank
records regarding real estate deals
joining us now with reaction is Jim
Warren the chief media writer for the
pointer Institute a Society of
Professional Journalists along with
Roger Simon CEO emeritus of PJ Media and
an Academy Award nominated screenwriter
I'd love to have that that bio after my
name Roger let's start with you Jam
you're you know you
present a Society of Professional
Journalists Jim this has been a wild
week for journalists given the mistakes
and the fact-checking and the sloppy
reporting and we just mentioned a few
there what are your thoughts especially
on CNN rushing out with this Don jr.
story this morning well yeah I mean
you're right in less than a week you
have this and you have the one I think
last Friday Brian Ross of ABC News it
was ultimately suspended for botching a
Michael Flynn story that targeted
president Trump and this in case people
missed it
abate the basic for us was that there
was a coziness between WikiLeaks and the
curious mr. Assange in the Ecuadorian
Embassy in London and Donald Trump jr.
as you just said the critical mistake
happened to be one digit September 4th
rather than the 14th and in fact by the
time the Don junior tweeted this as you
said all this stuff was publicly
available now I think a lot of this is
explained by the nature of the Internet
and putting a primacy on speed and I
think it's God's job I do with weekend I
think that I think mistakes go one way
that's why Jim I mean they always seem
to go against Trump they never seem to
be Wow the economy is even doing better
or or both the mother's going well there
hasn't found anything yet it turns out
mother has but you know what I mean it
so it always seems to go against Trump
so I think it hurts the media is
credibility Roger you can weigh and then
Jim can come back I'm nodding my head
for a reason I think that there is a
real psychological component in this I
mean why do television people make so
many mistakes and the reason I think is
a term for range min syndrome I think
these people hate Trump so much that
they'll grab a fact like that that is
bad for crump and just accept it without
doing the normal due diligence that any
intelligent reporter would do especially
from organizations like Reuters and CNN
which have tremendous facilities but
they don't do it because they're so
anxious to get him that's the hatred is
is what you know I think we all know
that hatred does bad things everybody's
head does it bad tomorrow
every time I'm hating somebody I can't
write well I think very well and I think
that's a factor here I don't know miss
yeah I don't know my colleague agrees
but I really find that I want to play
guys I want to play one more soundbite
from tonight's rally and have you both
react let's watch
they took this fraud ster from ABC they
suspended him for a month they should
have fired him for what a hero and then
CNN apologized just a little while ago
they apologized oh thank you see you
then thank you so much you should have
been apologizing for the last two years
Jim I think that the media they get
their back up when he says stuff like
this but it actually works I think most
people they're fed up with a bunch of
things in Washington they sick of
lawyers and they're tired of the media
and I think it plays right into what
most people think is that the media is
pretty biased and advice toward the
left-wing well I think one of the most
interesting pieces of survey information
I've seen the last year is how and I
think this is related to speeches like
tonight how you know only about a year
ago
Alaura about 75% of Republican 75% of
Democrats all supported the notion of
the media having a watchdog role that's
now dramatically changed among
conservatives and now that number is in
the 40s I think one does have a lot of
mistakes I do think there's a primacy on
speed which can trap many of us but
we're also forgetting of the spectacular
work that's being done every day of late
on the whole issue of sexual harassment
by the the New York Times and Washington
Post has also done a good job in the
fact that in case like Donald Trump jr.
today very quickly out of the box were
several media reports notably the
Washington Post for a terrific
comprehensive story calling out CNN and
making clear what exactly were the facts
here with Donald Trump jr. and at the
same time making note that there were
other examples that are irrefutable of a
fairly cozy relationship between
WikiLeaks and Donald Trump jr. when it
came to WikiLeaks at other times tipping
him off to stuff that was very
unflattering to the Clinton campaign all
right